You can say something ridiculous and then
say feminist theory and they're like,
oh, it's in feminist theory. Yeah,
yeah. That's the thing, right?
It's so much of the stuff they come up
with. Let me throw him on olive branch.
Like so much of the stuff they
come up with is a creative idea.
Maybe there's something to
some of this stuff, right?
But what they're putting
forward is hypotheses and
then they're treating them as
conclusions so they're putting forward
this idea. I saw one on Twitter today,
it was something like
there's about South Park,
how it's been laundering racism into
society and making everybody comfortable
with racism.
And that's why everything's so racist
and people are shooting Jews is because
southpark made it normal that they're
treating that as a conclusion.
But that's a hypothesis,
right? So we could test that.
It's conceivable that you could actually
try to parse out what variables need to
be controlled. C, you know, South Park
came out and started doing these themes.
What?
How does it track?
Statisticians can do kind of
amazing things with that stuff,
but they're not doing that. They're
not testing it and send it, testing it.
They're concluding it and they're using
theory to do so and they're like, oh no,
it's even bigger than that because
why don't they test it? Well,
if they tested it, and this is, I'm not
making this shit up, you won't believe me,
but this is true.
If they tested it and the test showed
that their hypothesis was wrong,
they would say that the test was racist,
but the test is condoning racism and
that's why it didn't give them the desired
result. How would you test something
like, cause I mean I'm not a statistician.
I actually am a mathematician,
but I'm not a statistician.
They're two different things. So I'm not
exactly sure how you would test that.
But conceivably you could gather data,
survey data and see how
attitudes have changed.
Maybe you could track kinds of articles,
kinds of events that are coming out.
You could kind of pair that up with
what's been shown on south park who aren't
self park and track out with attitudes.
I mean there's no effort to do this.
They're like, oh, South Park presents
these ideas, which they then cherry pick.
Cause there's other ideas that they
don't talk about their, you know,
point the other direction. These ideas
are problematic. That's the big word.
Theoretically that's a problem. Why?
Because they, and I'm not joking,
they literally believe that use of
language creates the power dynamics that
defined society.
So South Park's using language and
imagery that creates a power dynamic that
makes people more comfortable being
racist. Boom. It's theory done.
No tests needed. No even attempt to
test. And then if the test happened,
the test itself would be racist unless
it confirmed the hypothesis. Right.